[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم وانا راوي القاسم وهذه العربيه 260
الخبر
الدبابات تحديدا هجوميا لروسيا والاخيره
تتوعد
في تحذير لايران امريكا واسرائيل تحاكيان
ضربه لمواقع نوويه
يكشف سرا عن ارشيف ايران النووي
حكومه بشغات تردد بزياره ميلون المرتقبه
لطرابلس وتشكك في نوايا صفقه المؤسسه
الليبيه مع شركه
ايضا
حرب قانونيه بين قاضي تحقيق مرفا بيروت
والمدعي العامه تؤجل احلام القصاصه
وتطلقوا سرح الوقفه
[موسيقى]
تزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابات زخاما كبيرا بعد
ان اعلن الرئيس الامريكي
ارسال كتيبه كامله من دبابات ابرامز الى
كياف تتكون من 31 دبابه واشار بيض الى ان
عمليه التوصيل ستستغرق وقتا بسبب الانظمه
المعقده
تضايق عمل ناصر 30
دبابه ابرامز لاوكرانيا الامر الذي يكون
كتيبه اوكرانيا الوزير اوستن صاحب الخطوه
لانها تعزز قدره اوكرانيا على الدفاع عن
اراضيها وتحقيق الاهداف الاستراتيجيه
دبابات ابرامز هي الاقوى في العالم ومعقده
في التشغيل لذا سنمنح اوكرانيا قطع الغيار
والادوات التي تسمح بابقاء الدبابات عامله
في ميدان المعركه سنبدا بتدريب القوات
الاوكرانيه على تشغيلها في اسرع وقت ممكن
توصيل هذه الدبابات للمعركه سيحتاج وقتا
هذا الوقت سنستخدمه في التاكد من ان
الاوكرانيين قادرون على دمج دبابات ابرام
في جيشهام
وفي خبر عاجل مرتبط بموضوع تزويد اوكرانيا
بالمزيد من المساعدات العسكريه واشنطن
ترفض منذ قليل اي تحضيرات روسيه حياه لا
تصاعد الوضع في اوكرانيا بسبب ارسالها
لهذه الدبابات طبعا سيكون هذا ملفنا
ولدينا ضيف من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
حول ذلك
لعوده الرياضيين الروس الى المشاركه في
المنافسات الدوليه لانه يمكن للرياضيين
الروس المشاركه في المنافسات الاسيويه فقط
بالنسبه الى
المستشار الالماني او لاف شونس لدور برلين
الحيوي في دعم اوكرانيا وتزويدها بكتيبتين
من الدبابات
يعمل على تزويد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه
المانيا على دعمها اوكرانيا بمجموعه من
دبابات وتشكيله كتيبتين من الدبابات في
اوكرانيا اشكر المستشار الالماني على
جهوده في دعم اوكرانيا المانيا كان لها
صوت كبير في المجتمع الدولي من حيث الدعم
المقدم لاوكرانيا هذا الدعم المقدم
لاوكرانيا سيساعدها في تعزيز قدرتها على
المواجهه في خطوط الجبهه
من جهته يعتبر الرئيس
ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وقوات
احتلال اخرى ما زالت تحتل الاراضي
الالمانيه وتؤثر في قراراتها السياسيه
واكبر دوله اوروبيه لذا فقد اطفال اتحاد
السوفيتي صفقه رسميه على انهاء احتلاله
بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه تم تقسيمه
المانيا الى اربعه معسكرات كما هو معروف
المعسكر الامريكي والفرنسي والبريطاني
والسوفياتيه لذلك قام الاتحاد السوفيتي
باطفاء الطابع الرسمي على انهاء وضع
الاحتلال هذا على عكس الولايات المتحده
الالمانيه هذه حقيقه وهناك الكثير منها
اذا بيان امريكي بريطاني الماني فرنسي
ايطالي ننسق لارسال امدادات الاسلحه الى
كياف وجونكر بيقول قبل قليل ايضا انه ليس
لديهم دلائل على ان بوتين يخطط لضربه على
اراضي تابعه لحلف الناتو او منضمه الى
حلفان
اوكرانيا تنال اخيرا ما ظلت تسعى اليه منذ
شهور الدبابات الغربيه ستشق طريقها صوب
كاف لدعم القوات في اوكرانيا في الحرب ضد
روسيا طالما الانتظار قبل قبول المانيا
وامريكا ارساله دبابات وابرز لاوكرانيا
لكن الانتظار قد يطول ايضا من اجل
الاستفاده منها المهمه لم تنتهي بعد ويبدو
ان الطريق لا يزال طويلا قبل ان تستطيع
القوات الاوكرانيه تصويبه مدافع الدبابات
صوب الجيش الروسي فما هي الصعوبات التي
اتفو على السطح الان بعد الموافقه على
ارسال هذه الدبابات الجزء الصعب يتمثل في
نقل المركبات الى ساحه المعركه فقد كشف
مسؤولون امريكيون ان الامر قد يستغرق
سنوات حتى تصل دبابات ابرامز الى اي
مساحات قتال اوكرانيه وذلك بحسب ما نقلت
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز في تصريح اخر قال
الجنرال روبرت في ابرامز وهو جنرال سابق
في الجيش الامريكي سميت الدبابه على اسم
والده قال ان الوقت الذي سيستغرقه وصول
الدبابات لن يكون في 30 يوما بل دون شك
سيتطلب مده طويله
متاخر سيكون حجره امام الاستفاده استفاده
الاوكرانيين من هذه الدبابات فقبل
استخدامها على ارض المعركه يجب على القوات
الاوكرانيه ان تبدا تدريبا على كيفيه
استخدامها سواء لاوبر الالمانيه
كلاهما معدات تعمل بي تكنولوجيا متطوره
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه شددت ان الولايات
المتحده ستدرب القوات الاوكرانيه على
استخدامها هذه الدبابات قبل تسليمها كما
قالت المانيا على لسان المتحدث باسم
الحكومه انها ستبدا تدريب الاوكرانيين على
كيفيه استخدام الدبابات مشجعه الدول
الاوروبيه الاخرى التي لديها ليوبارد على
ان تفعل شيئا نفسها هناك تحدي اخر فيما
يخص الدبابات وهو امكانيه استهداف روسيا
للطرق او السكك الحديديه او اماكن انطلاق
المعدات اثناء شحنها الى الخطوط الاماميه
في شرق وجنوب اوكرانيا هذه اذن التوقعات
من ردود الفعل الروسيه ولكن ماذا عن
المواقف بالتاكيد ملف الدبابات شديد
الحساسيه بالنسبه لروسيا وايضا هي يعني
حذرت اكثر من مره بانه سيكون تصعيد خطير
لهذه الحرب وقد ينقلها الى مكان اخر
فامداد اوكرانيا بالدبابات الغربيه من
شانه ان يسب الزيت على نار المواجهه بين
روسيا والمعسكر الغربي فحلف الناتو
وواشنطن فعل تماما ما حذرت منهم مرارا
موسكو وهو تسليم دبابات متطوره الى كاف
وفي اول رد فعل على الخبر اكد السفير
الروسي لدى الولايات المتحده ان تولي
انتونوف ان هذه الخطوه تمثل تصعيدا خطيره
واكد ان بلاده ستقضي على جميع اسلحه
الكتله الغربيه في اوكرانيا بما في ذلك
الدبابات الامريكيه الحديثه الغضب الروسيه
بدا شديدا بعد قراري واشنطن وبرلين الى
درجه اعتبار ذلك تجاوزا للخطوط الحمراء
بهذا الخصوص قال رئيس الوفد الروسي في
محادثات فيينا كونستانتين جافريليوف ان
استخدامك هي في قذائف اليورانيوم من
دبابات ليوبارد سيعتبر استخداما للقنابل
النوويه القذره
منعرج جديد اذا تبلغه حرب اوكرانيا بتزويد
المعسكر الغربي
بدبابات متطوره وهي الخطوه التي تعصف
بمقترحات الحل الدبلوماسيه على مدى القريب
على الاقل ان وجدت ويبدو ان اداره بيدن
تدرك ذلك بل ولديها هدف ابعد فقد بدات من
الان بالتخطيط لمرحله ما بعد الحرب
الاخرانيه وذلك من خلال اقامه توازن عسكري
بين روسيا واوكرانيا وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي كشف عن الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
لنهايه الحرب الاوكرانيه والتي تقوم على
دعم اوكرانيا عسكريا من اجل خلق سلام عادل
ورغم تاكيد بلانك على ان بيد الله يتجنب
الصراع العسكري المباشر مع روسيا الا ان
واشنطن باتت ترغب في مساعدته كيف كي تكون
قادره على ردع اي عدوان في المستقبل
المفتاح هو اعطاء اوكرانيا الادوات التي
تحتاجها للدفاع عن نفسها من خلال انظمه
الاسلحه المتقدمه خاصه الدروع الجويه وهو
ما بدات فيه واشنطن من الانف ويبدو ان
اوكرانيا بدات تطمع اكثر فاكثر فوزاره
دفاعا تقول ان الخطوه القادمه هي المطالبه
بمقاتلات اف 16
[موسيقى]
حول هذا الموضوع
الامريكيه اهلا بك سيد ديفيد يعني
اكثر من مره
الدبابات توقعاتك لرد الفعل الروسي الا
يخاف هذا التحالف من 50 دوله تجمعوا جميعا
ليقدموا احدث التكنولوجيا المتعلقه
بالاسلحه
الا تخافون من عده فعله
التحذير وهكذا تهديدات الروسيه من زمان
من ضربه عسكريه نفذها
النوويه
كل هذا كلام فاضي
المحسبات دقيقه
جدا
وانا اعتقد انه نحن لا نخاف من ردود فعل
الروسيه خطيره
لهذا يمثل سعيد بدون شكل صحيح ولكن هذا
التسعي الدفاع
الحقيقه انه كل تلك الاسلحه من امريكا من
المانيا من فرنسا من دول التحالف بشكل عام
دفاعي يعني
لا تخافون لانكم بعيدون كفايه عن الاراضي
الروسيه اما المتورطون فقربون جدا وهم دول
اوروبيه ولو كانت حليفه لكم لماذا اعطت
واشنطن الضوء الاخضر لماذا يعتبر البعض
بانه ورطت بعض الدول في اوروبا بحرب اتون
حرب طويله المدى يمكن ان تنقلب الى حرب
نوويه
لا همم الحقيقه انه احتمال تحول الى حرب
نوويه خليل جدا جدا تقريبا صفر حسب تقييم
المهني
وحسب التجربه التاريخيه في العالم كله همم
ولذلك انا اعتقد انه القرار في همم الكلام
من السؤال الاساسي
اعتبر ان المانيا محتله واستحضرنا كل همم
مصطلحات الحروب العالميه او الحرب
العالميه السابقتين
المانيا فعلا محتله مستحيل كلام فاضي
دعايه روسيه وانا استغرب من هذا الكلام
كما يبدو للاسف الشديد الرؤوس الرئيس
الروسي ربما فقد الاقنانيه او المنطقيه
هذا كلام فاضي
والاسلحه الثقيله هي لضمان توازن ما بعد
الحرب الحرب الان دائره على الجبهات على
عده جبهات لماذا لا يتم التركيز الان على
ما يحصل على الارض
وهناك تحضير لما بعد الحرب
سؤال جيد لكن الحقيقه انه انا ارى التركيز
على الحرب وعلى ما بعد الحرب في نفس الوقت
وهذا طبيعي هذا عادي في العلاقات الدوليه
وفي الحروب التاريخيه في العالم كله نحن
مستعدين
لاستمرار للاسف الشديد هذه الحرب
العدوانيه الروسيه ضد الدوله مستقله دوله
اوكرانيا وفي نفس الوقت نحن
شروط او المناسبات
لانهاء الحرب والسلام عاديه ربما وسط لكن
هذا القرار يعتمد على للاسف كمان مره على
رئيس نادي ملكوتي
سا انقل لك بعضا مما يقوله المسؤولون
الروس ردا على هذا الكلام ولكن نتابع اولا
المزيد عن الموقف الروسي مع عبد الجواد
الرشد قبل ان يتاب في دورنا ناحيه
السفاره روسيا لدى المانيا تصف قرار برلين
بتزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات اليوبارد بالخطير
للغايه وان هذه الخطوه ستنقل الصراع الى
مستوى جديد من المواجهه اما سفاره روسيا
لدى الولايات المتحده فتتحدث عن ان تزويد
واشنطن لكيف بالدبابات الامريكيه هو
بمثابه عمليه استفزاز جديده لموسكو خارجيه
البلاد ترى في عمليه تزويد اوكرانيا
بالدبابات الالمانيه جزء من مخطط مسبق
لشني حرب على روسيا اما الكرملين فصرح على
لساني المتحدث الرسمي باسمه دي متربيسكو
ان الدبابات الغربيه ستصبح رمضان وسترق
مثل غيرها لكن الفرقه الوحيد انها ظاهره
الثمن وان دافعي الضرائب الاوروبيين كما
سماهم سيقعوا على عاتقهم في نهايه المطاف
دفع قيمته هذه الخسائر
ان يسمع
الاستمرار في العمليه العسكريه
الرد على قضيه الدبابات يجب ان لا يكون
محددا علينا لاستمرار والنتائج ستظهر
المعركه حاسمه ولا مجالا لاي خطه اخرى
بغض النظر عن ما قاله بسكوف عن تحريك
عقارب ساعه يوم القيامه اللي يتناولناه
بالامس راويه في العربيه 360 عشر ثواني
باتجاه منتصف الليل
يبشر من فراقه قريبه همم بريكوجين وهو
مؤسس شركه
يقول ان مهمه الولايات المتحده الان هي
تفتيت روسيا الى اقسام صغيره ثم بعد ذلك
التفرغ للصين والمنافسين الاخرين اذا
اعتبرنا فاجنر تنظيما اجراميا فان
الولايات المتحده هي اقوى اتحاد اجرامي
كيف تردون على هذا الكلام
كمان دعايه ههه
الحقيقه انه هذه الحرب عدوان روسي ضد
اوكرانيا دوله مستقله التي اعترفت بها
روسيا من 30 سنه تقريبا ولذلك كل هذا
الكلام محاوله روسيه فاشله
لخضر العالم
والمشاهدين الكلام انا اعتقد بصراحه كامله
وبكل احترام انا لا احد يصدق هذا الكلام
همم
ولا تصريح حتى المتحدث هذا بس وزاره
الخارجيه همم الروسيه التي قالت انه كان
في وجود لتخطيط مسبق للحرب ضد روسيا
والدليل كلام تستند اليه عن انجيلا ميركل
المستشاره الالمانيه السابقه بخصوص حديثها
عن اتفاقياتك التي اعترفت بانه منذ ذلك
الوقت كانت اوروبا والغرب يحضران اوكرانيا
لكي تكون قويه ل والان تواجه عندما تبدا
الحرب
ليس هودجوم او عدوان ضد روسيا هذا الدفاع
عن الذات من قبل اوكرانيا دوله مستقله
التي كما انا ما قلت من قبل دوله التي
اعترفت بها موسكو من 30 او اكثر من 30 سنه
لذلك ليس هناك اي تهديد
لروسيا نفسها بالاوكرانيا لا من قبل
المانيا لا من قبل امريكا لا من قبل
التحالف الغربي ولذلك كل هذا انا اعتقد
انه من اكذيب والعباد دبلوماسيه الروسيه
تصفها بالاكاذيب وامام هذا التدفق الكبير
بالاسلحه لا شك ان روسيا لن تقف مكتوفه
الايدي يعني هي تمتلك اعتدادا عسكريا
كبيرا ايران الى جانبها بالمسيرات التي
تزودها بها
في معركه وتحسد اعدا كبيره كما تقول
اوكرانيا على الاقل لان الحرب استعرت
عندما قررت وصف المانيا تزويد اوكرانيا
بالدبابات وبالتالي الى اي مرحله سننتقل
باطار هذا السباق بالتسلح بين الطرفين
عده مرات القرار بنسبه لايقاف همم الحرب
او على الاقل وقت اطلاق النار في ايدي
فلازم هو يمكن ان يخف هذه
العدوان في لحظه واحده ولكن هو للاسف يسر
على العدوان وعلى الاحتلال على الاكاذيب
وعلى الدعايه الروسيه الفاشله كما نحن كنا
نرى اليوم
والجيش الاوكراني يقول ان القوات الروسيه
متفوقه عدديا في شرق اوكرانيا وتكثف
القتال اذا ونتابع اي جديد فور وروده شكرا
جزيلا بوجودك معنا استاذ ديفيد بولو
كالمستشر السابق في وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه من واشنطن تحياتنا اليك شكرا
[موسيقى]
بالعربيه 360 ايضا
اللبنانيون والعراقيون في الشارع والهم
واحد العمله
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
الى تقديم اجابات حول اعدام ودفن المواطن
البريطانيه الايرانيه علي رضا اكبر
انه يتجاهل كرامه الانسان
ان السلطات الايرانيه دفنت جثمان اكبر في
طهران من دون حضور اسرته
وفي ايران ما تزال الاجهزه الامنيه تتحدث
عن ضبط خلايا تتامر على ان البلاد وزير
الامن الايراني اسماعيل الخطيب اعلن ان
الاجهزه الامنيه تعتقلت مؤخرا افراد اكثر
من 12 خليه ارهابيه مرتبطه بالموساد
الاسرائيلي واضاف الخطيب ان العدو في
اشاره منه لاسرائيل اذا كان يفكر في اسقاط
النظام الايراني منذ بدايه الثوره مسيران
الى ان هذه الخلايا التي كانت تهدف للقيام
بعمليات تخريب في الولاده مرتبطه باسرائيل
بشكل مباشر
لكن اسرائيل راويه تبدو منشغله الان بقضيه
اكبر مما تتحدث عنه ايران فتى الابيب لا
تكفوا عن توجيه الرسائل الى ايران والتي
دائما ما كانت تصفها باكبر تهديدا في
المنطقه اخر هذه الرسائل وربما اقواها هي
اجراء مناورات عسكريه مع حليفها الاول
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وذلك شرق
المتوسط مناورات
المناورات والاضخم بين البلدين ستتوظفوا
فيها اعتلى الاسلحه والمعدات العسكريه
فضلا عن عدد كبير من الطائرات وباستخدام
الذخيره الحيه
محاكاه مهاجمه ايران كان عنواننا بارزا
وصريحا خلال المناوره صحيفه تايم اوف
ازرائيل كشفت ان التدريبات ست تشمل اسقاط
قذفت استراتيجيه امريكيه ذخيره حيه على
اهداف في جنوب
والاهداف ستحاكي المواقع النوويه
الايرانيه وسيتم استهدافها ب 100 طن من
المتفجرات
هي المناورات الاضخم من نوعها اذا لاسيما
على صعيد التدريبات الجويه حيث تعرف
مشاركه
140 مقاتله امريكيه اذا تعرف هذه
المناورات مشاركه هذه الاعداد من
المقاتلات ومن بينها طائرات اف 35 والتي
ستحلق رفقه اثنتين واربعين طائره عسكريه
اسرائيليه اما التدريبات البحريه فتشهد
مشاركه اثنتي عشره سفينه حربيه امريكيه
الى جانب غواصه من البحريه الاسرائيليه
وحامله طائرات امريكيه وتجرى القوه البريه
تمرينا مشتركا يشمل اطلاقا عشرات الصواريخ
بعيده المدى من نوع هاي مارس الامريكيه من
منصات اطلاق اسرائيليه كما سيتم استعراض
قاذفه قادره على حمل قنابل نوويه من نوع
بيس 52 وعلى مستوى الجنود سيشارك ما يقرب
من سته الاف و500 جندي امريكي في
التدريبات بالاضافه الى اكثر من الف ومئه
جنديا اسرائيل
المناورات ايضا حملت في تفاصيلها رساله
اخرى مطمئنه هذه المره موجهه الى او من
الولايات المتحده الى اسرائيل رغم
التخبطات التي يواجهها رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو في مساعيه
لتشكيل الحكومه الا ان واشنطن او لبقاء
الحكومه الا ان واشنطن اصرت على اظهار
دعمها لاسرائيل بصرف النظر عن التطورات
السياسيه الداخليه ولا شك ان الالتزام
الامنيه الامريكيه تجاه اسرائيل باقي
وسيظل بغض النظر عن الشخصيات والحكومات
وهو ما كان شدد عليه وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي
بالقول ان واشنط انت تراجع عن دعمها
الراسخ لاسرائيل رغم الخلافات مع رئيس
الوزراء لكن كل هذا الدعم لن يخفي الخلاف
بين اداره بادن ونتنياهو فا جذوره راويه
تعود الى سنوات طويله مطر
فالحمايه الامريكيه للامن القومي
الاسرائيليه لا تخفي الشكوك حول امكانيه
حدوث شرخ في العلاقات بين البلدين خاصه في
ظل عزمنه ياهو اتخاذ خطوات تعارضها هذه
الشكوك رصدتها دراسه لجامعه تل ابيب التي
استعرضت ايضا اهم التهديدات التي يواجهها
نتانيا في السنه الجايه من بينها الازمه
الداخليه بعض الاصلاحات القضائيه التي
اقترحها والتي خلقت جدلا واسعا لكن
التهديد الاهم بحسب الصحيفه خارجيا في ظل
تربص التهديد الايراني باسرائيل الدراسه
كشفت ان اسرائيل تخشى ايران في الفتره
الحاليه اكثر من اي وقت مضى في ظل انشغال
الغربي وبخاصه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بالحرب الاوكرانيه الى جانب التهديدات
الاقليميه للصين فتلبيب مدعوه بمفردها
لمواجهه ايران وتحديدا برنامجها النووي
الذي يتقدم بسريه تامه كما تقول الدراسه
اسرائيل مضت بالفعل في مواجهه التهديد
الايراني وذلك بعمليه متواصله منذ سنوات
ليست بالقليله بل حتى ان الموساد
الاسرائيلي كان قد تغلغل في العمق
الايراني ونجح في سرقه ارشيف ايران النووي
والكلام هنا منسوب الى وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه السابق
في كتابه الجديد نافر
ان المخابرات الامريكيه ساعدت عملاء
الموساد على الفراري من ايران في فبراير
من سنه 2018 بعد ان في سرقه ارشيف ايران
النووي السري من قلب طهران بومبيه وصف
العمليه ايضا بانها واحده من اهم العمليات
السريه التي تم اجرائها على الاطلاق
ينضم الينا من القدس مراسل العربيه زياد
حلبي اهلا بك زياد يعني فعليا يقال عن هذه
المناورات الامريكيه الاسرائيليه التي
تحصل بانها الاهم ما التفاصيل التي تجعلها
الاهم
لا اعرف من يقول انها الاهم ولكنها بدون
اذن شك هي كبيره جدا ولكن الامريكيه
عفوا ضجيج امريكي اساسا وليس اسرائيليا في
الدرجه الاولى واساسا هي منورات امريكيه
اكثر تشارك فيها اسرائيل
اللافته كان هو التركيز فعليا على قصف
منشاه او محاكاه قصف منشاه ايرانيه في
صحراء النقب هذا تم اليوم حضر الموضوع
باليمين نتنياهو رئيس الوزراء ووزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي ايضا يقف غالاند الطلعه
على العام على مسرح العمليات عمليات القصف
باطنان من القنابل ومن ثم مغادره الاجواء
في خلال دقائق معدوده وذلك في محاكاه
لامكان ان تكون الضرب على هذه الشاكله ان
تمت يوما ما في الجغرافيا الايرانيه ولكن
يجب ربما الانتباه الى ما قاله نتنياه
هناك اساسا قال ان المناورات مهمه جدا
وتبين التعاون العميق بين الولايات
المتحده واسرائيل لكن اسرائيل سا- ايه
تعمل بشكل مستقل لتحميه نفسها بنفسها كما
قال بمعنى انها تفهم ان الولايات المتحده
تحاول فقط اثبات التزام امريكا تجاه
اسرائيل كموقف عام ولكن ليس بالضروره ان
يرقى الى ما هو اكثر من ذلك على الاقل في
ظل اداره ما تبقى منها
هذا صحيح جدا همم عمليا في اسرائيل همم
وحكومه نتنياهو يدركونا تماما بان لا خيار
عسكري امريكي ضد ايران همم وانما هناك
خيار عسكري اسرائيلي لم ينضج بعد لم يجاز
بعد ولهذا هنا قلق كبير في اسرائيل لان
ايران وفقا التقارير الاستخباراتيه
الاسرائيليه همم ما يفصلها وهو ليس اي
عائق تقني همم للتقسيب اليورانيوم الى 90%
في خلال ثلاثه اسابيع تملك مواد شيطريه
كافيه لاربع قنابل وبالتالي هذا الامر
ضاغط جدا على اسرائيل
وفي الناحيه الاخرى الولايات المتحده
تحاول وفقه مراقبين من هذا الضجيج العسكري
الكبير في المنطقه ان ترضع ايران عن اتخاذ
القرار بالمضيق نحو 90% ونحوه والقنبله
النوويه لكن في اسرائيل يقولون ان واشنطن
همم غارقه بالكامل في الموضوع الاوكراني
في الحرب على رانيا وفي مواجهه الصين وليس
في الموضوع الايراني وهو متروك لاسرائيل
عمليا همم عمليا ايضا يقال في اسرائيل بان
هناك الان محاوله للاستعداد لضربه جويه
حتى لم تكن جاهزه يمكن ان تنفذ عندما
تجتاز ايران الخط الاحمر للمفاهيم
الاسرائيليه همم المشكله في اسرائيل هي
انه منذ العام 2015 وحتى قرار ترامب
الخروج من الاتفاق النووي عمليا اسرائيل
كانت جمدت الاستعداد العسكري لن تتسلح لم
تتدرب فقط في السنوات الاخيره عادت الى
هذا الموضوع همم بقوه وينخصها التسليح
الذي جدول امريكيا من حيث التسليم
وبالتالي هذه قد تكون معضله كبيره امام
اسرائيل خلى ذلك هذه المناورات طبعا هي
ليست جديده همم سبق وتدربت مع الولايات
المتحده اسرائيل على قصف المنشات ب مقاتله
قبل شهرين عمليا انقطعت المسافه
المفترضه لايران فوق بلد اوروبي وعادت همم
عمليه
البريطانيين والايطاليين ايضا تدربت على
هذا الموضوع شكرا جزيلا لك زياد حلبي
مراسل العربيه من القدس على هذه المعلومات
والتوضيحات تحياتنا اليك
هذا الشيء
من الممكن ان تقوم الحكومه بضربه السباقيه
الايران لكنها لا تستطيع في نهايه المطاف
ان تمنع ايران من ان تكون نوويه في حالي
اراد ذلك ما كان مع العراق وسوريا ليس
مشابها مع ايران نحن نتوكل على الله
واناثق بان تقوم الحكومه بالله
اذا كانت هذه الحكومه ستضرب ايران لكنني
لا اثق بها
[موسيقى]
في ليبيا اشعلت الزياره المرتقبه لرئيسه
الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا ميلوني الى
طرابلس ازمه جديده بين الافرقه
مباشره
من تاثيره هذه الزياره على علاقات البلدين
على اعتبار انها ستزيد من مكاسب عملاق
الطاقه الايطاليه على حساب المصالح
الليبيه
واكدت انها ستلجا للقضاء
على ارادات النفط لعام 22 22 والبالغه
اكثر من 130 مليار دينار
من حكومه باشا ومعسكر الشرق الا انا
الاستعدادات للزياره قائمه وبقوه
وتفاصيلها مع منير الاشهب
تستعدوا طرابلسي لاستقبال وفد ايطاليه
رفيع المستوى مطلع الاسبوع القادم على
راسه رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه رفقه وزيري
الداخليه والخارجيه ومدير عام شركه
الايطاليه الذي سيقد اجتماعا مع رئيس
المؤسسه الوطنيه للنفط فرحات بنيدار مصادر
الليبيه تتحدث عن توقيع اتفاقيه النفطيه
مع شركه مما يعكس وتغيرا في ملفات السياسه
الليبيه الايطاليه
الفرنسيه المنافس المباشر لاني في ليبيا
خصوصا في ظل الانقسام الاوروبي تجاهها
الملف الليبي
معنى من بنغازي عضو مجلس النواب الليبي
النائب جبريل وحيده اهلا بك معنا سعاده
النائب نحن نريد ان نفهم منكم حقيقه
الموقف على الضفه الاخرى همم يعني السيد
بشاره مثلا اعتبر بانه هذه صفقه غامضه همم
وانها تقضي بزياده لا تسمعنا اذن طيب
سنحاول ان نصحح هذا الخلل
بريثما- يتم اصلاح يمكن ان نذكر راويه
بانه الحكومه المكلفه من البرلمان كانت
قالت بانها همم بانها ستلجا الى القضاء في
متابعه هذا الموضوع وان هذه الصفقه تقضي
بزياده حصه الشريك الاجنبي على حساب
الشريك الوطني المحلي اي زياده حصه
الايطاليه
ان يكون الاتصال جاهزا مع ضيفنا من بنغازي
نذهب الى لبنان حيث تراجع الحديث مشاهدينا
عن تحقيق القصاص في قضيه انفجار مرفا
بيروت يفسح المجال لتطورات الحرب الضروس
بين قاضي التحقيق طارق البيطار والنائب
العام التمييزي غسان عويدات
من قوه الامن مع قرارات النائب العام
التمييزي يعد انقلابا على القانون
التمييزي قال انه استدعى طارق البيطار
للموثولي امامه بعد ان ادعى عليه كما انه
قرر اطلاق سراح كل الموقف موقفين في قضيه
انفجار بيروت مع منعهم من السفر
في لبنان ايضا تظاهر العشرات امام المصري
في المركزي في بيروت احتجاجا على ترد
الاوضاع المعيشيه مع تسجيل الليره
اللبنانيه اليوم تراجع عن قياسيا جديدا
وارتفاع اسعار المحروقات
[موسيقى]
وفي العراق
المركزي في بغداد مطالبين بايقاف تهريب
العمله
امام الدينار سامر الكبيسي معه التفاصيل
يا محمد يا
[تصفيق]
ابن الشعراوي
هنا في شارع الرشيد بالقرب من مبنى البنك
المركزي قادمينا من محافظات بابل والنجف
وحتى بغداد والمحافظات الجنوبيه مطالبينا
بخفض سعر صرف الدولار والذي وصل الى
بدايات القياسيه
[موسيقى]
العراق من وسطه من جنوبه
يطالبون مطالب شرعيه منها خفض سعر الدولار
الذي اصبح كاهل على الشعب العراقي بعدها
مكان 120 118 صعد الى 150 بمقابل الدولار
العمله الاجنبيه وبعدين صعد الى 160 167
ربما 177
[موسيقى]
مطالب المتظاهرين تنوعت بين ايقاف تهريب
العمله ومحاسبه المضاربين داخل الاسواق
الماليه
يضاف لها عقد جلسه طارئه لمجلس النواب
لمناقشه ارتفاع سعر صرف الدولار امام
الدينار انهيار الدينار العراقي بما معنى
انهيار الدوله والسبب الاساسي لكل هذا هو
تهريب العمله ثانيه يجب ان تكون الحكومه
جاده وذات باعث وطني حقيقي
لايجاد حل لهذه المساله احنا شو بدنا نعمل
عقوبات دول احنا شعب نطالب يعني اول شيء
المفروض احنا كل الدول مو بس العراق كل
الدول تحارب من اجل عملتها من اجل التصعيد
عملتها احنا عكس الدول نحارب من اجل ننزل
عملاتنا مقابل العمله الاجنبيه
تظاهره انتهت بشكل سلبي بالاتفاق بين
القوات الامنيه والمتظاهرين لكن
المتظاهرين هددوا في حال لم يتم الاستجابه
لهذه المطالب بتظاهرات اكبر وربما حتى
اوسع في بغداد والمحافظات
[موسيقى]
بشارع الرشيد في بغداد سامر الكبيسي
العربيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا سنعود الى ضيفه نعود
الى ضيفنا
بنغازي اذن همم ونرحب بك سيد وحيد مجددا
ارجو انك تسمعني الان كنا نريد ان نعرف
منك موقف على الضفه الاخرى الحديث الان من
قبل السيد البشار على الاقل عن اللجوء الى
القضاء وعن اتهامات بصفقه غامضه تزيد من
حصه الشريك الاجنبي على حساب همم البلد
على حساب همم كل ما هو محلي همم ما
المعلومات المتوفره عن ذلك هل هناك همم
يعني ادله واضحه على ذلك ثم اي قضى وهل
يمكن ان ينفع الى القضاء في مثل هذا الملف
نعم مساء الخير بالطبع هذا ما بسطاعتنا
فعله سواء كان حكومه بشغا او اي ليبي غيور
على ما يحدث من عبث من حكومه الطيبه التي
مستعده ان تتنازل على كل شيء مقابل ما نحن
اي شيء للدول الانتهازيه في سبيل تصبغ
عليها بعض الشرعيه
وتمد في عمرها
وتدعمها سياسيا هذا ما يحدث وقد حدثت همم
مقابل رفعت دعاوى امام محاكم الليبيه
وابطلت كثير من القرارات بدء قرار اتفالته
وتوافق مع تركيا مع تركيا هذه اتفاقيه
المشهورها ابطالها القضاء وكذلك فيما
يتعلق حتى باتفاقات نفطيه ابطالها القضاء
الليبي بعد رفع الدعوه لان هذه الحكومه
مستعده حكومه تتنازل عن كل شيء همم وقد
تنازل حتى عن اللي بينا انفسهم بتسليمهم
خارج القانوني الى الولايات المتحده وهي
مستعده ان تسلم اخرين الامر لا يقف يعني
عند حد مع حكومه دبيبه والحكومات الاسد
والدول لا تنتهي هذه الفرص ايطاليا همم
قبلها تركيا وغيرها كثير يلتهم
مصالح على حساب مصلحه الشعب الليبي ولكن
مل- يعني الذي يمكن ان تفعلوه سياسيا او
قانونيا يعني الذي عددته عددته هو امور
يعني فعلتها حكومه ماذا الان عن القادم ما
الذي يمكن ان تفعله سياسيا او حتى قانونيه
ما فعلنا وان سحبنا الثقه منذ واكثر من
عام من هذه الحكومه
فيها هي غير شرعيه يعني تعتبر غير شرعيه
لدى الليبيين لدى مجلس النواب ونحن لا
نتعامل معها اطلاقا ما اعتبرها سلطه امر
واقع مدعومه من الخارج فقط والقضاء الليبي
وكفيل بابطال كل قراراتها الغير وطنيه
هل حاولتم فتح صفحه جديده مع سيد ميلوني
يعني معروف الموقف الايطالي منذ فتره
طويله بالنسبه الى ليبيا وانقساماتها ولكن
على الاقل كان في انتخابات جديده وكان في
غصون لي وجوه جديده واسم همم قيادي جديد
هل حاولتم فتح قنوات تواصل مع ايطاليا
الجديده
هذا دور الحكومه يفترى هذا الحكومه
المشكله لمجلس النواب ان تتواصل وربما هي
تتواصل ولكن ما نعرفه وان هذه الدول لغايه
في انفسها هي لا تعترف بهذه الحكومه التي
حدثت وفق يعني جاءت وفق ااا اتفاق ليبي
ليبي معروف وان هذه الدول لا زال تدعم
شرعيه الدبيبه المسحوبه منه الثقه
والمنتهي الصلاحيه حتى وفوق الاتفاق
السياسي الذي جاء به حاجه في انفسهم نحن
نشك في اخلاص هذه الدول وحتى مصداقيتها في
حال حاله الازمه الليبيه هي انتهازيه فقد
نراها انها دول انتهازيه تنتهز فرصه
الازمه الليبيه اللي تحقق مكاسب اقتصاديه
واستراتيجيه
الحوار القائم اييه اي مسار حواري قائم
بين الافريقاء المعنيين هذا الموضوع سيعقد
من جديد سيكون حجر عثره او يو سينهيه
لا هو ملامح الخرط الطريق الجديده اعتقد
انها بادت باتت تتضح الان مجلس النواب ومن
ورائه القوات المسلحه الليبيه همم امامها
ربما فرصه شهر قبل نهايه فبراير القادم
انها همم تاتي يعني تاتي بحل او بخرط طريق
ربابه بالتوافق مع طرف الاطراف الموجوده
هناك سواء
المجلس ما سبب مجلس الدوله الاستشاري او
همم حتى المجلس الرئاسي او حتى قوه فعل
على الارض هناك ربما والا حتى منفردا مجلس
النواب منفردا ربما همم يحاول بدا الان
بالفعل بتشكيل اللجان لهذا الغرض همم وضع
خط الطريق قبل نهايه فبراير القادم ليتم
تنفيذها ربما بدا في تنفيذ اعتبارا من
مارس
يعني تؤدي الى انتخابات ربما قبل نهايه
قبل حتى همم نوفمبر القادم
نحن الان ننتهز كل الفرص اما ان يتم توافق
مع قوه فاعله في الغرب الليبي سواء كان
مجلس الدوله اذا كان يعني نجحنا في ذلك
وشك في نجاح نجاح في ذلك وربما حتى مع قوه
اخرى في المجلس الرياسي وحتى قوه اخرى
مسيطره على الارض او طبعا مجلس النواب ليس
وحده هنا بالتاكيد هو مطلوب منه ان يكون
ايضا يعني هو معه القوات المسلحه في هذا
العام القوات المسلحه والا في النهايه
مجلس النواب وفق الاعلان الدستوري من حقه
كما فعل سابقا في همم ربما يعني صداقه
قوانين الانتخابات واعترف بها الكل ولكن
من عطلاتها هي القوه القاهره الموجوده في
الغرب الليبي والان كحل اخيرا اعتقد ان
مجلس النواب سيبدا في همم يعني وضع خريطه
الطريق
اليس تكريسا للتقسيم الموجود اصلا الان في
ليبيا
مجلس النواب لابعد حد في سبيل التوافق مع
هذه الاطراف التي لا اساس لها اصلا نحن
لازال في ليبيا يحكمنا الاعلان الدستوري
وهو الاعلان الدستوري لم ينتهي حتى الان
الاعلان الدستوري هو قائم الى ان يكون
ليبيا دستور دائم والاعلان دستوري يخون
مجلس النواب بل يحملوا المسؤوليه على وضع
هذا طريقه تؤدي الى تغيير المشهد نحن
نحاول التعاون مع ايا كان ولكن في حاله
عجزنا عن ذلك مجلس النواب لن يقف مكتوب
شكرا جزيلا استاذ جبريل وحيده عضو مجلس
النواب من تحياتنا اليك
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا ونذكر بالخبر العاجل
على الهواء عن الشرطه الاسبانيه التي
تتحدث عن اعتقال المنفذ الهجوم هجوم الطعن
بالسيف كان يحمل السيف ساموراي في كنيسه
في جنوب البلاد وتسبب بمقتل شخص في 2022
اكثر من 300 مليار دولار تبخرت تبخر ذلك
الذي ينكره الكثيرون تغير المناخ
[موسيقى]
اليوم
دولار في عام 2020
حاله بين فيضان واعصار
وحريقا خلال 20 عاما مضت ذلك
من ينكرون اصلا وجود التغير
والا فيديو اليوم وهو من ليبيا يخاطبهم
البحر جهزوا اكياسكم هذه رسائلكم ردت
اليكم انقلب قارب جديد بمن يحمل قد يكون
الغرقا عشره اكثر او اقل وقد يكون الناجون
عشره اكثر او اقل لن يمثل العدد فرقا
ابن جسورا بين الضفتين او اوقفوا العبور
لديكم اكثر من حل حل
الى صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 في غزه
تلمع عيون الاطفال وترتسم البسمه على
وجوههم مع قصص علي بابا
اي قصه خياليه عنها تتحقق قصه عن امير
نبيل عن ساحره شريره او عن حيوان يتكلم
حتى عن زائر من الفضاء لكنه لن يحكي ابدا
عن قطاع عمته المصالحه ولا عن قطاعا رفع
عنه الحصار لانه يعرف حينها انه سيكون
الكذاب
نهايه العربيه 360